the electric grid is undergoing a
dramatic change increasing adoption of
renewables and storage at the boat grid
are increasing variability and
flexibility consumers are adopting
electric vehicles smart appliances
storage and solar enabling them to
become prosumers who can actively
participate in wholesale and retail
markets system operators utilities and
aggregators are able to access
increasing amounts of real-time data and
they use it to plan monitor and operate
the grid the digitization of the
electric grid leveraging the
availability of massive data cheap cloud
computing and rapidly evolving data
science and AI will result in a
transformation of the ecosystem it will
lead to the emergence of new
marketplaces pricing strategies novel
services and opportunities for increased
automation and autonomy this radical
transformation is taking the grid beyond
the traditional concept of smart grids
the aim of this course is to introduce
you to the modern electric grid and
focus on major transformative
technologies renewable storage prosumers
electric vehicles and artificial
intelligence each topic is covered as a
module and they connect to the basic way
the grid works today after the class you
should be able to understand how the
grid works how it's changing and what is
the role of key technologies and
important opportunities this class
offers a good background for engineers
investors and policymakers interested in
this space to engage in activities such
as developing new solutions identifying
opportunities for innovation and
assessing impacts
you